you're also shooting the prom and and
you're working with Meryl Streep yes
you're playing her love interest in
playing Meryl Streep's lovage this is I
mean yes life is good life is good
really good these are because we're
trying really can't be any better yeah
[Laughter]
yeah it's Eddie Murphy
Meryl Streep I'm on a lot of medication
right now it's very diluted but acting
with Meryl Streep would be I think just
be like Simon saying oh why don't you
pick up that fiddle and just play next
to Mozart yeah it looks like it's like
oh god I get to be the right receiver
who's the quarterback Tom Brady yeah
it's it's it's really it's surreal and
to also be her to play the love interest
it's not like I'm just walk I mean I
would have been happy to walk in the
background and just be like you're a
coffee ma'am I wait a bit you know but I
didn't
there's not even a table there but it's
at at any rate I love that you also did
your line and then looked right to
camera like your coffee ma'am yeah which
is totally what I am NOT an movie actor
or any kind of actor that's exactly what
we do
[Laughter]
your coffee sir that's the least of my
problems
no I but it was interesting so we've
read the script and we find out you know
that I'm gonna be your love interest and
we share a kiss we have a kiss in the in
the movie and my you know my wife she
knows what I do for a living she's in
the business right and so it's one of
those things where it can always be a
little you know when you're like she you
know I know I've had to kiss people in
the past and then I was like oh we're
reading the script
oh we're gonna kiss Meryl Streep she
goes you better go get that DNA swab
just in case it's what I do before swab
the cheese Mike was cloning technology
to keep it under wraps